elizabeth and mary they're so unique and
in a number of ways
oh i'm sorry
you get so lost in it
you know what i didn't even know i was
on tv easy to do all right will the left
listen to bill maher and admit they've
gone too far we're about six months out
from the midterms and many house stems
are toast and they know it one damn
strategist tells the hill the website
not the generic mound of earth that
wouldn't make no sense
i think this is going to be a biblical
disaster this is the reality we are in
as democrats and no one wants to face it
end quote the strategist was then fired
for mentioning the bible boy a lot of
bible today huh so
what got them here well there's
inflation immigration war cove mandates
and crime
not to mention the old ghoul floating
around the white house like a plastic
bag in a parking lot
that's the best description so you can't
blame voters it's all on the dams and
their absurd policies for example smiley
martin the alleged sacramento shooter he
was given a 7 500 settlement from the
city just weeks before the shooting
that's more money than i make in a day
yes so no wonder the sob was smiling
apparently he filed a lawsuit in 2018
involving a jail guard but because the
courts were backed up they just paid him
off california pisses away more money
than i do after drinking gold infused
vodka
so yeah we're now giving payouts to mass
shooting suspects no wonder even
long-time lefties like bill maher are
calling out dems these days here he is
telling joe rogan how things have
changed
i feel i'm the same guy but five years
ago
uh you know we hadn't spent six trillion
dollars
to stay home i mean i understand we had
to do something with the pandemic i'm
not sure that was
you know i mean i remember when a
trillion dollars was too much to spend
on anything we didn't spend a trillion
to bail out
the economy in 2008. five years ago no
one was talking about abolishing
the police
you know there was no talk about uh
you know
pregnant men and you know i mean there
was
looting was still illegal have i changed
no because if someone had said 20 years
ago i i'm not sure looting is a bad
thing i would have opposed it then see i
so i haven't changed
maybe you haven't but you sure are
sounding more and more like someone i
know
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah godlike
you know cat yep
that was that was a male response
so you know you know what's happening
now to bill maher he's being cited as a
conservative yeah is that hilarious but
it's i've kind of had that happen to me
where people think because i'm
libertarian always having people like
you've become more conservative but it's
it's not that like i used to be to the
left of most democrats on criminal
justice reform because of my views on
the drug war but now that i think that
you should go to a jail for assault with
a deadly weapon
that makes you concerned that makes me
apparently conservative yes you're now
in the john birch society yeah i haven't
become more conservative i've just
declined the invitation to becoming
completely insane which is what so much
of this stuff is but i don't know if
it's gonna get any better because i feel
like when you're in such a crazy
situation and you're saying all these
crazy things you get used to it yeah and
they don't they probably don't even
realize just how crazy they sound if
they're in these bubbles where
everyone's saying that kind of yeah it's
funny if you're in a bubble for a long
time you kind of just become the bubble
you know tyrus it seems like the dems
are more worried about losing power
than the actual consequences that led to
that like they're not worried they're
going oh my god we've got to solve crime
we've got to solve this and that instead
it's like oh we're going to lose power
yeah well it's not even that i think
this is actually a good thing what we're
seeing i know that sounds crazy given
when you step outside your neighborhood
and see what's going on we're seeing the
end of tribalism
at the
thank you to the democrats the
progressive push so hard they just
thought that their troop would go with
them yeah yeah and at some point being a
human being
and being safe and is more important
than wearing
the blue donkey on your on your shirt
because they've gone so far that they're
left center
is now considered conservative right
so what does it mean to actually be
conservative it means you want small
government you don't want them on your
back you don't want them in your pocket
you want to take care of your family and
improve your life right that in itself
is probably if you ask every american
who wasn't trying to push their side of
the fence they would agree with you
that is more important to them now than
belonging to the troop because the troop
is back crazy and they're not going for
the ride anymore that's why
bill maher is suddenly going why is he
hates he hates the republicans he has
beef he doesn't he thinks that we don't
like the environment he has all those
little issues but when it comes down to
basic human being rights and being a
human being and taking care of yourself
he kind of agrees with us there yeah
that's right you know uh
whitaker sir this guy in sacramento
how
how can human beings agree to something
like that like just pay off a guy and
then he goes and he kills a bunch of
people right right there's been four
people arrested in that
mass shooting event yeah all four of
them were either bloods or crips one of
them had a device to make his pistol
automatic
and they essentially it was a shootout
at the okay corral right you know this
wasn't somebody walking into a walmart
and yeah not to make light of mass
shooting events because they're very
serious but this is this was gang
violence in the middle of sacramento and
this guy got out four years of a 10-year
prison sentence for domestic violence
all four of the people that arrested all
had felony domestic violence and this is
i'm going to bring you my punch line
here california has the most restrictive
gun laws yeah on the books and all four
of these guys were felons and should not
have had guns right and so to me it is
not a matter of enforcing the laws it is
that we are allowing
violent criminals to under serve their
sentences and then putting them out on
the street hoping that
that it turns out different and then oh
by the way we did give them seven
thousand dollar settlement um for
something that happened in jail
the last time he was yeah it's biz it
makes no sense and this is why a lot of
americans just shake their heads at
california because this is the type of
policy that democrats want to spread all
the way across that's the scary part is
that it's it's not shrinking it's
growing you know shannon do you think
that you're going to be on bill maher's
book to discuss uh the the
very first time i ever was on tv was on
his show oh politically incorrect likely
and correct okay that's a good point
that was like
25 no no no no yeah exactly 25 so he
can't actually say
that he's not partly responsible for
this because he had all that time to say
hey guys maybe he did
and i don't remember it well but the
thing is i think tyrus makes such a
great point about people getting out of
their tribes over this stuff
all my mom friends were furious about
all the school stuff over the last
couple of years they also feel scared
they don't feel safe they worry about
traveling or having you know their kids
on the road when you look at things like
real clear politics average of how do
you think the country is is it moving in
the right direction it is upside down by
37
the democrats have the white house the
house and the senate so that is not a
good number for them going into the fall
if people feel like the country is is
you know basically going to hell in a
hand basket what yes did
just greg real quick yeah i mean if
there was one guy can we put that do we
have time to put that picture back up
he literally has a blueprint on his face
that he's a murderer
he's killed at least three times and he
received an award for it he has the
diamond tier which means he's a master
at his craft that didn't tip you off
that that's not the guy yeah you cut a
check what do you think he did with his
75 he loaded up
just amazing to me god i got to get one
of those tattoos maybe i'll finally get
the chicks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else